[Music]
in Elon versus Escobar news
submitted by Tokyo ghoul Pablo Escobar's
brother is planning to sue Elon Musk
over his flamethrower what but didn't
they have flamethrowers in Germany and
then there's been around since World War
one right yeah maybe the name is you
know flamethrowers are not illegal in
California or was it Georgia they're not
illegal in one of the states I think
maybe here because we they sold it here
we were able to buy it
mm-hmm it's like a bat the backpack one
although the heavy-duty it's technically
not a flamethrower eyes as a
flamethrower that's why I don't get
where they still make the backpack one
like every single video game has taught
us that like the backpack flamethrower
is never a [ __ ] good idea
shot in the back yeah yeah literally
you're throwing fire with a backpack
full of gas
like it's not games but I appreciate the
info or just movies like how many movies
you see where the guy with the
flamethrower it goes well for him like
he does it really well don't see girls
do that I see a red barrel in a movie in
like real life though no so haven't seen
it in real life but saw it like like not
in a movie where people were just
actually shooting like a like a
scarecrow and things like that
it's pretty crazy like it's nuts dude it
leaves a trail of just fire on the floor
too because of the gasoline is it so
Roberto Escobar the 72 year old former
accountant for his late brothers million
cartel farmer and accountant I wonder
what he farms former former owners
resume he says accountant it says
Medellin Cartel no I was thinking farmer
and accountant and I'm all like is he
farming the coca plant
oh there you go farmer accountant former
accountant whatever anyway appointed
former accountant and brother yeah
so he is now threatening to take down
Elon Musk with a 100 million dollar
lawsuit for stealing his plans for a
flamethrower because he says that back
in
20:17 must company stole the idea during
a trip to the Escobar compound so he
claims that the idea of a toy
flamethrower came from the from the way
that the escobar brothers the the way
that they would burn the mountains of
cash in order to keep them warm
so he's insisting that the model being
sold by musk is actually their
copyrights Wow where's the patent but
he's he is currently selling his own
flamethrower like a must is not a human
dude he's the [ __ ] he's not real did
you see the picture of him Baldy yeah
Bobby and me at the gate hair plugs put
it looks way better you know those
things work dude I gotta get that [ __ ]
so this is the boring companies which is
the ulemas company's flamethrower and
then this is Roberto Escobar what other
ways there that you can make it no sir I
mean look at they look really really
like how they got like a model of
everything you know they're also bikini
yeah so that I'd buy it just because of
her man wait that's the same [ __ ]
exactly it's identical and it's cheaper
so that one no I think this one I can't
remember but I remember thinking dan
that's cheap yeah so then but then the
Roberto's once 250 bucks or maybe was
cheaper than that 50 that's pretty good
for a flamethrower oh yeah well it's
marked down cuz it used to be 500 and I
should buy a couple of them me too
that's on it that's cheap it's getting
one that sells hot man no because the
Boyne company no longer fun but you know
it's a it's the same technology as those
lighters with the blue flame like the
like the blowtorch yeah just kind of
maybe right and then [ __ ] Elon Musk
hands up reply oh no don't yeah on
Twitter he's like he says um [ __ ] where
is it well it was something to the
effect are like mr. Escobar
it is not a flamethrower because that's
literally the name of the flamethrower
it is not or not a flamethrower so
that's how you response to this oh come
on I need this guy alive they made it a
limited release
yes the Bourne company did and they
claim to have sold to 20,000 that's all
yeah because that's the whole boring
company's modelled it's like just the
first thing was a hat and there was a
limited release everything it's not for
the money it's just for fun I know and
you know what else
what's fun camp what subscribe to this
channel thank you and never miss a
single one of our video image click on
the bail leak but yeah so everyone's
looking at this story and thinking
really dude I don't want to [ __ ] with
any sort of former or current cartel
people ever like I'm all I will always
want to be on the good side cuz I think
it's real it's [ __ ]
Escobar's brother though many and so
done it's over dude
I don't know they're all connected
though there's connected to the new guys
that leaders there's their friends it's
just all yeah yeah I don't know but they
were at war with the new guys so I'm not
that they're just too scary for me
there's all no the same circle Elon is
like lightyears ahead of them in
security and mice plenty of stuff so why
is that a nice pun Oh cuz he's
light-years and it's it's illness but
we've never had Lightspeed well you
don't know what do you almost caused us
I know he's turning headlights me though
game would be groundbreaking do you get
that I mean he changed the role with the
car that drives itself it's really dude
we're trying to get to the memo it
really just cause a lot of crashes the
blood is [ __ ] people going like what
the [ __ ] you said this is autopilot I
think crash not yugioh I'm talking about
my people
what are your people grow dumb white
people who bought a car that says
autopilot and anything it works I like
that and they fall asleep on the [ __ ]
road and hit autopilot button and
they're like I'll get home safe and they
wake up in a ditch white people this is
a wake-up call okay this is an
intervention for you
about what no white about white people
and they wake up and they're looking for
attorneys the next day her sue a long
months I bet that's a lot of money
look I've been uncomfortable all the
time with Steve green here I just no one
say anything
but I like white people they're cool
awesome fun anyway so escobar here he's
saying we will soon file a one hundred
million dollar case against him in
america and i will try my best to make
sure he loses his stronghold in tesla
inc
he knows exactly what he has done to us
why is it so late true he was busy
selling drugs they sold that [ __ ] out
like a year or two ago mm-hmm there's
2017
yeah I would I buy it I'm gonna buy it
well you can't anymore it's done
nobody would Kim's on bringing up his
brother to he says Elon Musk is a person
that betrays people pablo never betrayed
anyone
people only betrayed him this was their
mistake and usually it cost them their
life such as nature people are
ungrateful because I watched a TV show
dude do Gallois and what I know of Pablo
is a misunderstood man yes and he is not
only a pillar of the community he is a
Robin Hood not a taco
yeah that's the one I'm devoting the
Netflix TV show of Pablo Escobar's
by Auto graphically biography biopic
biopic yeah what is it an autobiography
horse at a biography autobiography means
he wrote it yeah when he does it on his
own right yeah I thought it was because
it was connected to automobiles but well
this in this case I would think I would
say that everything is always about how
bad this guy like the drug dealer is but
he's built so many hospitals food banks
he did so much good in Colombia I mean
it so many judges killed cuz like Dave
they were disagreeing with him so and
children to [ __ ] those kids do what you
gotta do yeah they're in the way
exactly my point you during the way of
building hospital right sometimes you
just gotta do what you got to do to do
good kill some kids to build some
hospital that's what you said yeah it's
a really dark that's a Pedro Flores I
mean
kids built some hostage casualty of war
no one goes out wanting to do it but
sometimes you know it's like you gotta
get on a road trip to go somewhere
beautiful but you don't want to [ __ ]
hit a deer damn so another thing that
you Roberto was talking about here was
uh so he's now claiming to have a secret
new product that he believes will
destroy Apple he says I need around four
years to make you bigger than Apple
things move fast and technology within
the next month we're going to launch our
first product I cannot tell you what it
is but it will be much better than
anything
Apple ever did this one I call papaya I
will be I don't know I feel like apples
like they losing me man
I [ __ ] love Apple but come on man
come out with something good you don't
let it - what are they losing about uh
they're just not advancing enough for me
like before they were like
groundbreaking it was like some dope
[ __ ] now I'm like ah
Apple's never been groundbreaking just
just on PC I think I follow they make
great phones when it comes to computers
they make the worst [ __ ] computers
like you're just buying the brand that's
all your price [ __ ] of all it really
is like if you buy like a mac tower and
you buy the same specs on a PC it'll
cost you half the money most of people
who like design right here baby
there's always this talk about like
aren't they don't they edit faster or
don't kind you do graphics unlike normal
like never leaks to a different what
about porno viruses haha that's the
thing
Mac's are so popular now that the
viruses are as frequent as in Windows
took like 10 years man for them to catch
up so now there's less portal viruses on
linking sees it's hard you know what I
mean it's hard to get porno viruses if
you go just to save porn sites you know
if you just stream and you don't
download or just don't gotta like creeks
just go to the you know the branding is
dope dude cuz that that was a good laugh
because of your pervasive disabled or
non community I built it it's
constructed man for you you did it thank
you
it took a long time to piss the poor
did it I work hard and I work hard my
cue to the pornhub rewards you belong
there man I was like how dare you should
have presented an award you know how
much I care and it's like if if Eminem
was here and we didn't invite Nikki like
you guys know how much oh my god I can't
wait till that happens I so don't want
to invite her just for the baby it's a
good thing I have to meet him you guys
know how much I care about porn yes
who's your favorite porn star
I don't like porn stars that's how legit
I am you know when you're oh my god that
small this video you have to understand
that [ __ ] is considered hack to him he's
into the amateur amateure that's like
saying like that's like saying like
you're a filmmaker right which one's
your favorite director no like that's
like saying like like what's your
favorite you know Shurmur shal
commercial ass movie that everyone likes
let's favor Michael Bay movie yeah
exactly
he likes the in how's that the same no a
shame
[Music]